الله اكبر الصراع في السودان يتواصل في
اسبوعه الثالث وتساؤلات عده تشغل بال
الكثيرين حول النزاع المستمر حتى اللحظه
فماذا يحدث في السودان
عده تفاصيل فجره الموقف قبل موعد نقل
السلطه للمدنيين منها الجدول الزمني لدمج
قوات الدعم السريع في الجيش اضافه لمسالتي
تسلسل القياده بين الجيش والدعم السريع
والاشراف المدني على الجيش
للنزاع في السودان جانبان الجيش بقياده
عبد الفتاح البرهان وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدان دقلو وهما في ذات الوقت
رئيس ونائب رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي
على التوالي كما ان الرجلين شارك في
الاطاحه بنظام الرئيس السابق عمر البشير
عام 2019
العديد من الدول العربيه والافريقيه
والغربيه دعت منذ بدايه الازمه لوقف اطلاق
النار ومع استمرار النزاع بدات تعمل هذه
الدول اضافه لعدد من المنظمات الاقليميه
والدوليه بالعمل من اجل التوصل الى هدنه
تشكل ارضيه لتحقيق وقف دائم لاطلاق النار
على ان يتبعه التفاوض بين طرفي الصراع
وصولا الى عوده السلام الى السودان مجددا
وفي الاثناء بدات مختلف الدول باجلاء
رعاياها ومن رعايا دول اخرى من السودان
انهيار حكم البشير عزز امال السودانيين في
ان تتمكن بلادهم من الخروج من الصراعات
الداخليه الجهويه والتي اضيفت لها العزله
الدوليه الا ان الصراع الحالي ربما يزعزع
الامل مع استمرار الصراع والدمار الذي لحق
بالعاصمه السودانيه ايضا وكما العاده في
اي صراع ربما يتحول السودان الى ساحه
منافسه على النفوذ في المنطقه بين مختلف
الدول الاقليميه اما الخطر الاكبر فيتمثل
في احتمال وقوع السودان في براثن حرب
اهليه جديده اضافه لعرقله الجهود المدعومه
دوليا لاطلاق عمليه انتقاليه نحو الحكم
المدني حسن غوليد العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات